Let's use last.fm's API as an example, and let's
see how we can interact with it to get
data and find out the top albums in the US, China, and Spain. As you can see on
the left hand side here, there are a few
different last.fm API methods that we can talk to
and retrieve information from. For example, let's check out
the album.getInfo method. As you can see this page
tells us the type of data that the API
method will return like artist name, album name and
a bunch of other information such as language or
a music brains ID from the album. But the question
is now how do we actually get to this
data from last fm's API. It's actually really simple. We
can simply copy and paste a link like this
into the web browser. And look at all the information
that last.fm returned to us. Okay, now I
want to point out a few interesting things about the
URL. See all the parts after the question
mark? That's how we define API parameters. Like the
method. The API key, the artist name and
the name of the album that you want data
for. So for example, if we wanted information
on a different Rihanna album, like the album Unapologetic,
we could simply change the album parameter
here from Loud to Unapologetic. Let's see if
that works. Look, we now have the
data from Rihanna's album, Unapologetic. Pretty simple, huh?